euh qui est ben évidemment ou euh où les
des combats on vous le signaler en ont
eu lieu autour d'un site militaire qui
vous ou le maire vient par ailleurs de
de s'exprimer Clovis Casali bonjour vous
êtes notre envoyé spécial dans la
capitale
ukrainienne le maire de Kiev vient à
l'instant de s'adresser à la population
de la ville il leur donne il instaure un
couvre-feu on imagine évidemment que la
nuit qui qui se profile va sans doute
être encore plus difficile que celle de
la veille en tout cas psychologiquement
absolument et de nombreux hôtels
commencent à déjà évacuer leurs clients
des hôtels tout simplement parce que le
personnel appuie le personnel a quitté
qui est comme de nombreux habitants
qu'on a vu toute la journée toute la
journée qui ont quitté cette capitale
ukrainienne en voiture on les a vu faire
des faire la queue à des stations à
service de nombreux embouteillages à la
sortie de la capitale
ukrainienne et vous l'avez dit l'armée
russe qui vise en priorité des
installations militaires
ukrainiennes et notamment les forces
entières aériennes
ukrainiennes donc les autorités ici à
Kiev inquiète toute la journée ont
essayé de lancer des messages des appels
au calme et aussi pour essayer de garder
un certain niveau de morale au sein de
la population et les gens à qui nous
avons parlé et bien sont partagés vous
avez ceux qui quittent qui est pour
aller plus vers l'ouest plus en sécurité
et vous avez aussi ceux qui ont décidé
de rester ici à Kiev notamment on a
rencontré avec Rob parson Abdallah
un Ukrainien qui fait partie de ses
forces d'autodéfense c'est volontaires
qui sont là des réservistes prêts à
intervenir prêt à s'engager si
nécessaire et cet homme Timothée nous
disait qu'il est prêt à aider prendre
les armes il y a une loi qui a été
passée c'est tout dernier jour pour
autoriser les Ukrainiens à se rendre
dans les armureries les autoriser à
acheter des armes en vertu d'une
autodéfense pour se défendre contre
l'envahisseur russe c'est dire que les
Ukrainiens sont prêts mais ils sont
forcément dans la crainte et dans
l'inquiétude et ici à Kiev vous l'avez
dit il y a eu des combats aux alentours
dans autour de la capitale on a entendu
des explosions à toute la matinée mais
il y en a eu d'autres aussi dans
l'après-midi à environ 20 30 km de Kiev
et bien sûr ici les gens sont inquiets
et se demandent si les Russes vont
essayer de marcher vers la capitale
effectivement ce scénario évoqué depuis
plusieurs semaines et que les ukrainiens
et en premier les habitants de de Kiev
ne croyez absolument pas cette
possibilité d'invasion cette option de
voir un jour les Russes arrivées jusqu'à
la capitale il faut le rappeler on est à
des centaines de kilomètres de la ligne
de front plus à l'Est on dit aujourd'hui
que Vladimir Poutine a en tête d'avancer
jusqu'à Kiev pour y installer de
nouvelles autorité pro russe est-ce
qu'on commence à y croire un peu plus
aujourd'hui
toute la journée c'était
l'incompréhension chez les gens on a
même rencontré des Ukrainiens qui nous
disaient c'est pas possible les Russes
n'ont pas pu envahir non pas pu mener à
cette opération et forcer de constater
qu'au cours de la journée au fur et à
mesure des heures avec des Ukrainiens
qui seront énormément sur les réseaux
sociaux
auprès de sources sûrs mais aussi auprès
de leurs proches de leurs amis qui sont
un peu partout dans le pays et bien ces
Ukrainiens forcément commencent à y
croire c'est pour ça que vous avez
toutes les boutiques tous les
restaurants ou presque on en a vu un ou
deux en traversant la ville qui était
encore ouverte tous ces restaurants ces
boutiques qui restent fermées les
employés qui ne sont pas venus au
travail ou ces boutiques qui ont fermé
au cours de la journée et bien ces
ukrainien soit vont prendre à Brive vont
vont à l'abri dans des abris ou dans le
métro ou chez eux ou tout simplement ont
pris leur voiture pour quitter cette
zone en tout cas la menace précise
l'inquiétude grandit ici et comme je
vous le disais très peu de gens ici dans
le centre-ville de Kiev à maidane qui
d'habitude
est très très occupé et bien aujourd'hui
il y a très peu de gens dans le centre
de Kiev c'était pas le cas dans d'autres
quartiers de la capitale où les
ukrainiens et bien elle est au
supermarché pour acheter des vivres
faire des provisions il faisait la queue
aussi aux stations-service et on s'est
entretenu on a communiqué avec un des
patrons d'une entreprise qui gère
l'arrivée d'essence de pétrole qui est
dans ce secteur là et qui nous disait et
bien qu'aujourd'hui il y en avait encore
dans certaines stations mais que demain
il ne savait pas car il y a le problème
de l'approvisionnement d'essence en
ville notamment parce qu'une certaine
partie vient de l'étranger et donc
forcément les routes sont coupées
l'approvisionnement est compliqué et
donc les ukrainiens et notamment ici à
Kiev essayer de trouver des solutions
déjà dès à présent un mot peut-être
aussi de l'attente de ses Ukrainiens on
a entendu tout au long de la journée ces
différentes chancelleries et chefs
d'État s'exprimaient en dernier lieu
Emmanuel Macron qui a exprimé évidemment
sa solidarité envers les Ukrainiens nous
tiendrons aux côtés des Ukrainiens dans
les jours qui arrivent les 27 se
retrouvent ce soir à Bruxelles à 20h
évidemment pour ce coordonner et pour on
imagine montrer au reste du monde une
image une image d'unité qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent les Ukrainiens de l'Europe
demain
alors déjà vous avez le président
ukrainien Zelenski qui a appelé assez de
coalition anti Poutine une coalition
pour mettre un terme pour empêcher cette
invasion russe ces opérations de grande
envergure coordonnées et vous avez la
population
ukrainienne on a parlé avec un Ukrainien
qui nous disait qu'il ne comprenait pas
pourquoi l'Occident pourquoi les
États-Unis pourquoi d'autres puissances
n'avaient pas agi avant car c'est vrai
personne ne s'attendait à une opération
russe aussi rapide surprise mais
beaucoup de gens ici en Ukraine
imaginaient que les velléités russes
étaient énormes et que le président
russe envisageait bien sûr cette
opération
contre l'Ukraine donc oui ici beaucoup
de gens attendent de l'aide de
l'Occident que ce soit militaire ou pas
ou diplomatique en tout cas les gens ici
ne cherchent qu'une chose c'est la paix
ils ne veulent pas voir les forces
russes forcément
arrivé ici à Kiev c'est le c'est
forcément l'inquiétude et la crainte
numéro un vous pouvez imaginer la
journée ils se sont réveillés à 6h du
matin avec ce son ses explosions aux
alentours de Kiev toute la journée des
sirènes pour leur demander d'aller à
l'abri de ce réfugier et aussi on a vu
toute la journée des ambulances
traversées Kiev mais il y a aussi de
nombreux blindés et même des chats dont
les rues de Kiev l’armée ukrainienne qui
est mobilisé bien évidemment le
gouvernement ukrainien qui dit déplorait
déjà des dizaines de morts côté armés et
aussi une dizaine au moins chez les
civils et des dizaines de blessés ce
chiffre est à prendre avec énormément de
précautions car forcément il augmente au
fur et à mesure des heures au fur et à
mesure de cette opération de grande
envergure mené par les Russes contre
l'Ukraine merci beaucoup